c'est pendant les concerts c'était la
fête et on sentait les gens beaucoup
plus détendue beaucoup plus heureux
qu'on al'impression vous aimez pas trop
notre époque d'aujourd'hui présente on
jette ça va oui ça fait pas changer ça
c'est de la merde
vous dire c'est curieux que le temps de
leurs huit ans peut plus boire en plus
fumer un peu plus voyez ce que je veux
dire on peut au beau but rien
c'est vrai que c'est à cause de gens
comme thil verde bref je trouve non mais
je vous le dis franchement je vous fait
pas du bien non vous croyez vous fait du
bien nous fait énormément de mal et tous
vos amis là comme vous dites vos amis
mais
non mais non mais franchement c'est un
support and on sait bien que vous donnez
votre avis dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
et le quotidien avant pouvait conduire
vite boire fumer je suis désolé suis
content qu'on conduit ce plus vite si on
boit pas et consignes passées mieux
aussi donc faut arrêter c'est un truc de
vieux de dire que c'était mieux
aujourd'hui si la pression quand tu
attends michel sardou a l'habitude moi
je suis assez d'accord sur blanche neige
c'est insupportable sur la ce qu'ils
auraient fait ce qu'il avait fait au 6e
l'oréal c'est parce qu'ils avaient fait
n'importe quoi mais j'ai des ennemis
mais ce qui m'a de films et beaucoup de
compte qu'un mythe c'est juste la police
de la sens de la binationalité tout le
temps on en fait on n'en peut plus voilà
je vous le dis vous êtes d'accord avec
michel sardou c'est ça c'est
insupportable et donneurs de leçons il
endormi j'avoue mathieu mathieu sur
jeanne originaire de choc avec tout ce
qu'il dit je suis contre tout ce que dit
gilles sont de manière assez général
c'est vrai parce que j le problème c'est
plutôt à vouloir en fait je pense que tu
part d'une bonne intention qui est
d'unir les genres est vrai que tu les
diviser ces noirs contre les blancs gay
contre contre hétéro c'est latino contre
machin n'est qu'à 1 1 contre grand et
tout ça tu te dis vive tout le monde or
il faudrait justement unir tout le monde
devrait quoi qu'il nie tout le monde
bah oui mais tu es chez toi
et la série louis ce galaxy mais ce gars
là il passe son temps à fracturer la
société à nous donner des leçons à
m l'égoïsme
le plaisir personnel comme le pinacle de
la société y'a que d'un l'ormeau si la
société que vous voulez c'est la société
de l'égoïsme ou de l'ormeau se dit le
meilleur mois cette société je rejoins
sardo c'est de la merde
société les gens qui font quelque chose
mais sinon il ya celles comme la tienne
tholot et aux postures but sur une
chaise comment tout ce qu au pôle
espoirs n'ont jamais rien [ __ ] jg
c'est vrai mais je vais pas commenter
pour
[Applaudissements]
ban
voilà
oh
des gens de ta famille
[Applaudissements]
les chevaux castaldi euros
et
[Applaudissements]
basata cet avis a commenté
j'ai mille fois moins
[Applaudissements]
te marier
jamais de petite taille qui meurt et qui
me dit est ce que gilbert et de l'iphone
ou race ils vont nous lâcher la grappe
et si vous plaidiez april qui vient
d'arriver
toi quoi tu en parles quel que soit le
sujet avec west ait des gays des noirs
oui on est on est on est bon c'est
génial on est regardés